okay economic policy aside domestic
policy aside foreign policy aside
malignant narcissism aside we've been
following the outlandish and by
heartbeat bizarre behavior of Donald
Trump for a couple of years now if
you've seen some of the interviews that
I've done about this topic you know that
there are numerous serious mental health
professionals in the United States who
have identified that Donald Trump's
mental state seems to be declining at a
moderate pace his speaking abilities his
ability to express himself dynamically
and articulately he was able to do this
20 years ago go back and look at
interviews he was able to do it even ten
years ago better than he is today that
ability has been notably declining for a
period of time now that exceeds his
presidency it even goes back to the
campaign a little bit some mental health
professionals we talked to you are
calling it a pre dementia State others
are calling it subclinical cognitive
decline that may not yet meet clinically
diagnoseable sort of levels some others
are saying no this is actually
clinically diagnoseable at this point or
there's kind of a mix here between a guy
who is just in his 70s now and not in
particularly good health
combined with personality disorders
however you want to sort of qualify it
or quantify it one of the signs of this
sort of behavior includes Trump circular
speech repeating the same words very
often without sort of being able to snap
out of the circle and make whatever
point he has in mind that he's trying to
make being unable to fully express
himself and actually carry through a
point from start to finish his my uncle
nuclear weapons a Wharton speech is an
example of that go back and look forward
on youtube if you don't remember that
one so what I have for you today is
really strange video that is only
raising even more concerns about this
this is a new video from over the
weekend Donald Trump was trying to tell
a story I think about how former
presidents George W Bush and Barack
Obama built parts of a bad wall like a
wall that's not good
the Mexico border and then Trump became
oddly fixated on doors in the wall and
again it's just anyone's guess what he's
trying to say he seems unable to snap
out of it is trump putting the doors in
is he not are the doors good or bad
expensive or cheap it's not clear what
Trump is talking about and he seems
unable to even make a point you know
when you talk about previous
administration so we have a stretch
along the Rio Grande where you people
know exactly where I'm talking at it's
about 38 miles done by actually both
previous administrations it was sort of
done as a combination of one going into
the other and it's a wall not a good
looking wall it's a wall
it's got 36 doors at at big doors very
big doors and then never put the doors
on so it's 38 miles with 36 doors that
you can drive a truck through there's
only one problem they never put the
doors on it so we're putting the doors
on it or even better maybe not putting
any doors I said maybe you do it without
the doors because putting the doors on
cause more than the property is worth
I'd rather give the money for the
property and just say bye-bye you're
selling to somebody on the other side
but I mean literally putting the doors
on course more money I said what's the
property worth on the other side much
less than the doors these are doors with
the hydraulic they need hydraulic
because they're so heavy which is
ridiculous in itself but so that's the
kind of thinking that went into this so
now we're filling up those big those big
gaping wounds in this wall this is
somebody who's in a fog I mean he
doesn't know what he's talking about a
wall with 36 big heavy doors with
hydraulics which is ridiculous in and of
itself and as he says the the wall the
doors weren't actually put in its 36
doors you can drive a truck through
but there aren't doors so he's putting
them in except maybe he's not and maybe
we give the money for the doors to
somebody else it's really important to
understand this is Trump off-the-cuff
okay I get that he's awkward with the
teleprompter but this is what happens
without one and it didn't get any better
during other parts of this speech they
say and this is our new statement the
system is full can't take you anymore
whether it's a sigh
whether it's anything you want it's
illegal immigration can't take you
anymore we can't take you our country is
full our area is full the sector is full
can't take you anymore sorry can't
happen so turn around that's the way it
is so I got another weird moment where
he gets into these repetition comas it's
not clear what he's saying the country's
full the area's full the sector is full
this is not normal communication for a
72 year old who is of sound mind I'm not
making fun of Trump
I yeah I I think he's a fool I think he
is ignorant on almost every single
political issue I believe he's an
embarrassment to the United States
around the world this is not about any
of that this is about possible cognitive
decline that rises to the level of a
diagnosis
condition period it's not funny it's
it's not something that we should be
making fun of it's something that no
country should have a president who's
cognitively declining and not able to
think straight and what would be great
is if we could put partisanship aside
for a second I don't like his policies
people on the right do like his policies
this has nothing to do with policy I
don't know what he's talking about I
don't think he knows what he's talking
about because he gets into these cycles
where he's repeating the same words he
can't stop he forgets what point he's
even trying to make and it's not the
behavior of somebody who is fit to be
President of the United States and as we
know because of the uncontrollable leaks
that come a nonstop out of this White
House there are people working closely
with him who have the exact same
concerns let me know what you think is
going on I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
follow us there and there is so much
news from this weekend that I will be
getting to glad you're with us today
today's program is sponsored in part by
zip recruiter I've talked before about
the fact that while I do handle the
hiring at the David Pakman show
hiring is not an extraordinarily
exciting or fun activity it's hard to
find qualified candidates it can take a
long time sometimes there
to many applicants and it's hard to sort
of sift through who might be a good fit
there is one place you can go though
we're hiring is simple fast and smart
and we're growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates and that is zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there they use their powerful matching
technology to scan thousands of resumes
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
the applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and right now my viewers and listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com / Pakman that's zip recruiter
comm /p a que ma n zip recruiter dot-com
/ Pakman it is the smartest way to hire